by anyone's measure
china's belt and road initiative is a
massive project
trillions are being spent on
infrastructure linking china to the
world
by road rail sea and pipelines
reinvigorating the ancient trade routes
from
china through central asia to europe
africa and the middle east
to south asia and india an
ambitious upgrade which is now an
ecosystem
in itself hello i'm huslinda ahmed
welcome to the new trade superhighway as
we continue to navigate
china's belt and road initiative
[Music]
we begin this program here in mumbai
known as a gateway to india
a symbolic entry point of the world's
largest democracy
but not so welcoming to china's belt and
road initiative
two countries with massive economies
accounting for more than a third of the
global population but
with a long history of mistrust
well i think it's understandable that
india is nervous about having this giant
neighbor that's just growing so quickly
and it's frankly outpaced india in a lot
of ways so i understand
india is nervous about this doesn't want
china to be planning the asian
infrastructure
but there is potential for india to
benefit if china is financing
good infrastructure projects around the
region many of the countries which have
gone in for belt and road projects
sri lanka for example and some central
asian republics
run the real risk of getting into a debt
trap amongst india's immediate neighbors
pakistan maldives and sri lanka the
three countries which we think
in our assessment can become highly
indebted
they've always been concerned about
china because they share a border and a
contentious border a disputed border and
they've always been concerned about
pakistan
so if the question is should they be
concerned about bri
i think they'll be most concerned when
it's touching upon countries that border
them where they have
traditionally had their sphere of
influence so
whether it's a rail line to nepal
whether it's a port in bangladesh or a
port in sri lanka or cpec yes they will
absolutely be concerned about it
at the heart of india's opposition is
the biggest single project of the belt
and road initiative
the china-pakistan economic corridor
which snakes its way from one of china's
westernmost cities
through the disputed territory of
kashmir all the way
to the arabian sea cpc so far
to date is probably the biggest single
component of bri
it's very important to pakistan china
has not overnight but in a relatively
short period of time
reduced for example the energy shortage
that pakistan has had the electricity
shortage so it's very important to
pakistan recipient it's also important
to china because pakistan has been an
ally of china for a very long time it's
a counter
counterfoil to india and it gives them
access to the arabian sea so
it also borders a sensitive area of
china which is xinjiang province so
it's important for both parties that
actually succeed if i'm a commercial
enterprise and i make an investment
which is not viable i take the hit and i
move on as a government
my concerns are not only financial i can
for example in case of sri lanka i have
a 99 year lease on a port
right now which sits very close to india
and which sits right next to a major
international shipping lane i am also
investing a billion plus dollars in
gwadar a port in pakistan which is also
not likely to be financially successful
so i can get these assets right now
which are commercial ports but which in
the longer run can have other uses as
well
we have already seen in case of djibouti
which is which is debt ridden most of
which is owed to china
now put part of its territory for use by
chinese as a military base
some of this is definitely strategic the
corridor from china down through
pakistan
it's hard to see that this is very
economic you know
going over the himalayas to get from
china to pakistan that's really not very
practical
so that seems like a strategic move on
the chinese part
i can understand why india would worry
that it's being surrounded as china
builds that infrastructure in pakistan
if you put all of india's rail tracks
back to back they would
circle the globe one and a half times
eight
billion passengers a year that's the
official number
it's much more if you add all the people
who travel for free
across this vast nation here at mumbai's
hub during crush hour
7 000 cram crammed trains made for just
1700 the system is antiquated
in need of upgrade i see the mood in
india changing
you will have quite strong investment
from the aib
which is investing for example in the
mumbai metro which is the town
city we are in is an example of
cooperation
around india's infrastructure now you
don't have to call that the belton road
initiative
that could have happened without the
belt and road initiative the the reason
why belton road has been so
enthusiastically taken up by many of
india's neighbors especially
sri lanka nepal and pakistan is partly a
failure on india's part
to deliver connectivity to its own
neighbors if you look at india state
with this
immediate neighbors with pakistan it's
obviously minimal because of historical
reasons
but india has also been unable to
develop any meaningful infrastructure
and connectivity with nepal
in the last several decades the similar
case exists in case of bangladesh
where we have very little connectivity
either in terms of energy or in terms of
good transport
and the same thing is true in case of
sri lanka as well
mumbai was one of the original stops
along the ancient silk road
its port remains the country's largest
accounting for almost half of all its
container traffic
it's also home to the indian navy's
western command
looking west across the arabian sea to
pakistan
and the middle east and to the east the
riches of southeast asia
and ultimately china
[Music]
so some of the defaults such as sri
lanka are not surprising at all
you look at the size of the economy you
look at the kind of investments that
have been made
and you also look at the individual
projects humber dota port gets a traffic
of i think one or two ships every week
so it's not surprising that the project
has gone down under
and i think something similar is likely
to happen in case of gwadar
which is again about a billion plus
dollars is being invested if you're a
recipient country
in bri doesn't matter where you are and
china comes along and you negotiate
um let's say appropriate terms for
whatever the project happens to be there
aren't a lot of other competitors
beating down your door
so this has been china's huge advantage
they bring not only the funding but also
the expertise to actually execute
and that is a very compelling package
for a recipient country
you but the recipients do have to be
careful of the financial terms
so from india to central asia that's
where we're traveling next
as we continue to navigate china's belt
and road
initiative
one of the countries that stands to gain
most from china's belt and road
initiative
is kazakhstan where in the capital
astana administrative hub of the world's
largest landlocked country a country
locked between china and russia at the
center of a balancing act between
geopolitics
and economic advancement
astana is an ultra modern city built in
the oil riches of what is by far
central asia's dominant economy
a city celebrating its 20th anniversary
and a birth date of the country's one
and only
president
no sultan nazarbayev has ruled
kazakhstan since
independence from the soviet union in
1991
seen here opening astana's international
finance center
a bold move five years in the planning
to link
the region's capital markets much like
his country has embraced its role as a
key
overland pivot of china's belt and road
initiative
the key agenda of the economic policy of
the government is the diversification of
economic
diversification towards creation renew
subsectors of our economy
in a different industrial dimension but
also the services sector
and among these we financial services so
we
want to be the financial hub of the
region we want to help to religion to
develop
the economies and i think in this terms
kazakhstan in a very good
track to deliver it we are naturally the
first country
that lies to the west of china as we go
towards europe
and we have built our own infrastructure
even before the initiative was launched
we have built
2500 kilometers of railroads
to reconnect east and west of the
country so when the initiative was
launched
this infrastructure came in handy we
were prepared
and we are now cooperating with the
chinese on implementing numerous
projects there is a
program uh to implement 51 projects
worth 28 billion dollars in kazakhstan
jointly with the chinese they are
relating to belton road initiative but
not exclusively so it's
it's a very wide range in economic
cooperation of course one of the
key benefits for us is that we're
transit country
and transit is a very good
way of making money and then doing
business in our country for example we
have finalized the
kazakhstan part of western china western
europe super highway which is about 3000
kilometers long
it costs us something like three million
us dollars and that one goes to the
russian border
another route is taking us to the
caspian sea
and to that end we have built a new port
in kurik
on the on the shores of the caspian sea
and that route takes us across the
caspian
to azerbaijan georgia and then from
georgia to turkey and from turkey to
mediterranean
and further west and yet another one
is the railroad that takes us from the
caspian from from macdow to
turkmenistan and iran and to the gulf so
we we have
diversified our transportation routes
and we have
provided for various alternatives
not only going north west but also going
south
on kazakhstan's border with china are
plans to build the world's largest
dry port built on the kazakhstan not far
from what is known as the eurasian point
of inaccessibility
that's the farthest point on earth from
an ocean
nearly everything that crosses into the
west
by rail from china passes through here
the chinese invested into that 50 50
with us so
we have a train now that can uh travel
from
yanyongang in the um east of china
to through china to horgos then through
kazakhstan
and to istanbul in about two weeks
and we want to we want to decrease the
um
um the the traffic time they did the
transit time
to about 12-10 days so this part of the
world used to be the heart of the silk
road
for centuries and centuries in the past
and right now as we recreate the silk
road in
asphalt and rail now in still
kazakhstan again is recovering its place
as the key crossroads in the heart of
eurasia give us a sense
of the sectors that will benefit in
kazakhstan when the
maritime communication came in it stole
away the show if you will
now gradually land communications are
taking hold the industries that stand to
benefit the most
are obviously construction processing
petrochemistry
the products of petrochemistry are
needed in road construction but also
agriculture and food processing
already i can tell you that the volume
of container transportation across
kazakhstan from china to europe
grows twice in size every year for the
past
seven years and it will reach two
million containers by 2020
so kazakhstan stands to gain about five
billion dollars
in transit feed transit fees every year
just down the road from the port is what
kazakhstan and china
are calling an international free trade
zone
dual cities on either side of the border
a planned strategic silk road city that
for all intents and purposes for now
lies in a no man's land during the cold
war this whole
area was a controlled military zone the
two towers you see behind me
represent the borderline i'm on the
kazakh side
the chinese side is almost fully
developed but kazakhstan says
it has big plans to catch up cargos is a
gateway to the chinese market so we
agreed between two governments
china and kazakhstan so we're going to
develop this special economic zone
regime which will help us
to develop the trade hub over there so
the idea is that in the soviet union
time probably it was bottleneck and now
we're gonna
kind of ex increase the breakthrough
capacity for the goods coming
in both direction but
five years after it was first proposed
on the kazakh side at least
this project remains a work in progress
some people have said that kazakhstan
will be the buckle
of the belt but there are challenges
before that can happen
as i said we have built the
infrastructure we have also
worked very hard with our other
neighbors such as russia and belarus
to establish the eurasian economic union
we are prepared in terms of synchronized
customs tariffs and synchronized
synchronized
railroad tariffs so we have not only
built a hard infrastructure in
those 2500 kilometers of railroads
but we have also created soft
infrastructure if you will removing
barriers for trade from kazakhstan
in central asia to south east asia
that's next as we continue to navigate
china's belt and road
initiative
[Music]
for the countries in asean china's
belgian road initiative
offers massive opportunities where
infrastructure is key to economic growth
from indonesia to the philippines
myanmar to laos
malaysia to here in thailand projects
worth
hundreds of billions of dollars are
underway to improve
connectivity
we can have the physical high
performance connectivity in place
then we can see that that would help
spur
activities in terms of commerce and
investment
this is one of the backbone
of medium-term economic outlook
for indonesia i'm sure starting next
year the productivity gain
from the infrastructure being developed
will be start to kick in to us threat
our economic growth we are not going
into building
airports and hoping they will come we
are improving our
airports because they are already
currently congested
we are improving our ports because they
are congested
we are improving our roadways it helps
us
achieve our build build build program
and second because
it promotes not only connectivity within
our country
but also outside of our country
like many of its neighbors thailand is
betting big on the belton road
investing tens of billions with the help
of china to turn its eastern provinces
into an economic corridor
and billions more on projects like this
a high-speed rail from here in bangkok
all the way
to china
the mecca station will serve as
bangkok's rail hub for fast trains
heading north to china
through laos and south to singapore
through malaysia
although that part of the journey is now
in jeopardy
it will also link the country's three
main airports to thailand's eastern
economic corridor
the eec we have planned it to be
a catalyst so to speak of connectivity
not just in thailand but also with
other countries especially our
neighboring countries now china and
students
of us so it's natural that the eec
can link up with the build and grow
initiative you could practically see a
corridor
running north china south
through thailand and to to asia
all the way each country has to look at
their own interests
has to make sure that uh you know
whatever
loans they incur are are affordable not
only to this generation but
to the subsequent generations the two
loans that we have
negotiated the first one is for a
dam it's a 62.5
million dollars and the second one is
for the development of a municipal water
project that's around 200 million
dollars
we are currently negotiating a large
larger loan and this will be
approximately
2.8 billion us dollars and this will be
for a railway project
again improvement of a railway project
that is already
you know in in in bad rip in a state of
bad repair
we have set up actually in indonesia the
priority infrastructure projects and
based on that
we identify which project that we feel
we can then propose to to be to be
included in the bir
the biggest challenges in that is really
the execution
out of the 50 at the moment we only were
able to utilize about nine
so we are still very far to go so while
the funding is there
there are also a number of requirements
that we have to follow
in order to get that other risks of
unmanageable costs oh i think
there are definitely many right i think
this is not just about
uh baton rouge as you know indonesia at
the moment is in the reform process
a lot of the infrastructure projects
that's happening right now
has issues such as regulatory issues you
know
licensing we have obviously manpower we
have
also land acquisitions issue there's a
number of also local issues
i think that we also have to solve
in order for this to be maximized
another of the key routes for china will
be its corridor through myanmar
and local issues there throw up all
kinds of questions
the country borders china india and
bangladesh
providing not only a channel to the
indian ocean
but also overland west to the indian
sub-continents
there are concerns over many aspects
large infrastructure projects would
incur a lot of indebtedness
and there's a lot of concern in this
government over
the the risk of over-indebting the
country and passing on that to the next
generation
and i think that's a positive con you
know thing to worry about
the fact that we're not just going all
out in building things not without
regards for our
budget position after years of strict
military rule
myanmar's infrastructure is in urgent
need of development
making it a prime target for the belt
and road initiative
the other concern would be how the
construction of these projects will pass
on
in terms of technological know-how as
well as human resources
into the country unfortunately for many
years china has been supporting myanmar
but sometimes in ways where myanmar
people would feel that they haven't
really gained very much
so there you have it the views from
india
central asia and southeast asia on
china's belden road initiative
i'm haslinda ahman thanks for watching
[Music]
you